this woman is an exception she calls the
shots Vince estas eloped when traffic
permits I try to get through fast if I
can drive 200 kilometers an hour I will
gridlock makes that out of the question
but her career is moving fast for more
than 20 years Sylvia pretorius vice has
been an executive at one of Germany's
biggest industrial concerns she's also
on the advisory board of a steel company
in Germany's industrial heartland the
Ruhr Valley here she's taking part in
the advisory board meeting at the shaven
company she's the accounts expert and is
always asked to report the latest
figures ok tell off the clearly see how
high the costs were and so draw a
conclusion whether it was worth it for
shaven for 2000 entered the company's
top managers need to justify their
actions to a three-member advisory board
that a woman is one of the trio in this
sector is very unusual in Germany do
women on advisory boards work
differently than their male colleagues
in Wisconsin ELISA he had to to be quite
honest I've been in the steel business
for 50 years and women haven't always
been well respected oh I'm gazebo so I
was hesitant to tell the truth about
putting foul pretorius forward but in
fact I got the opposite of what I
expected from senior and junior
management finally a woman good I don't
know if I work differently than my male
colleagues league w fallen today women
are a bit more meticulous for example
when i showed the advisory board around
a big trade show what was most
interesting where all the things from
pretorius wanted to have a look at it
was the advisory board wants to see that
everything's running smoothly shaven
produces steel for building heavy
industrial machinery this year the
company is expected to
120 million euros in turnover but that
will only happen if every customer gets
their steel components precisely as they
specified about 500 people work for the
company more than eighty percent are men
but there are exceptions even in
leadership positions for example a woman
is in charge of materials testing what
do your male colleagues say have they
gotten used to a woman telling them that
a part is flawed the problem is that i'm
not very tool but it's working I know
that problem now we'll make the hammer
it weighs 45 kilos yeah Pretorius wants
to find out all there is to know about
testing steel quality that is it severed
or bent when she was the same age there
were no jobs for women in this sector
when I applied for my first job as a
trainee at a steel industry association
it's a right now that I'm on a steel
company advisory board but back then I
received in writing that I was turned
down because I was a woman become
unhappy appeal in college and over now
she's telling the bosses what to do but
she says it would be good if she weren't
the only woman in the room I favor the
quota to ensure the debate doesn't die
away and we can take a few steps forward
after being the lone woman at an
advisory board session there's a meeting
for women as well a business leadership
Association has invited women to a
regular get together
the men the men invented the student
clubs and they've been networking for
centuries women really need to make up
for lost time their power is still
unequally divided only one in ten
members of the advisory boards of
Germany's major companies is a woman